The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Quick, quick recap
of what we did last time.
So last time we introduced
this idea of decomposition
and abstraction.
And we started putting
that into our programs.
And these were sort of
high level concepts,
and we achieved them using
these concrete things called
functions in our programs.
And functions
allowed us to create
code that was coherent, that
had some structure to it,
and was reusable.
OK.
And from now on in problem
sets and in lectures,
I'm going to be using
functions a lot.
So make sure that you
understand how they work
and all of those details.
So today, we're going to
introduce two new data types.
And they're called
compound data types,
because they're actually
data types that are made up
of other data types,
particularly ints, floats,
Booleans, and strings.
And actually not just these,
but other data types as well.
So that's why they're
called compound data types.
So we're going to
look at a new data
type called a tuple and a
new data type called a list.
And then we're going to
talk about these ideas that
come about with--
specifically with lists.
All right.
So let's go right into tuples.
So if you recall
strings, strings
were sequences of characters.
Tuples are going to be similar
to strings in that they're
going to be sequences
of something,
except that tuples aren't
just sequences of characters,
they can be sequences
of anything.
They're a collection
of data where
that data can be of any type.
So a tuple can contain
elements that are integers,
floats, strings, and so on.
Tuples are immutable.
And if you recall, we talked
about this word a little bit
when we talked about strings.
So that means once you
create a tuple object,
you can't modify it.
So when you created
a string object,
you were not allowed
to modify it.
So the way we create tuples
are with these open and close
parentheses.
This shouldn't be
confused with a function,
because there's
nothing-- there's no--
this isn't a function call.
It's just how you
represent a tuple.
For a function call,
you'd have something right
before the parentheses.
This is just how we chose
to represent a tuple.
And just a plain open
and close parentheses
represents an empty tuple.
So it's of length 0.
There's nothing in it.
You can create a
tuple that contains
some elements by separating
each element with a comma.
So in this case,
this is a tuple that
can be accessed with a variable
t that contains three elements.
The first is an integer,
the second is a string,
and the third is
another integer.
Much like strings, we can
index into tuples to find out
values at particular indices.
So you read this
as t at position 0.
So the tuple represented by
a variable t at position 0
will evaluate to 2,
because again, we
start counting from 0
in computer science.
So that brings us-- gives
us the first element.
Just like strings, we can
concatenate tuples together.
That just means
add them together.
So if we add these
two tuples together,
we just get back
one larger tuple
that's just those two-- the
elements of those tuples
just put together
in one larger tuple.
Again, much like strings,
we can slice into tuples.
So t sliced from
index 1 until index 2.
Remember, we go until
this stop minus 1.
So this only gives us one
element inside the tuple.
And this is not a mistake.
This extra comma here actually
represents a tuple object.
If I didn't have
this comma here,
then this would
just be a string.
The parentheses would
just-- wouldn't really
make any difference.
But the comma here
makes it clear to Python
that this is a tuple with
only one element in it.
We can slice even further to
get a tuple with two elements.
And we can do the
usual operations
like get the length of a tuple,
which says, how many elements
are in my tuple?
And len of this t
would evaluate to 3,
because there are three
elements inside the tuple.
Each element, again,
separated by the comma.
And just like strings,
if we try to change
a value inside the
tuple-- in this case,
I wanted to try to change the
value of the second element
to 4-- Python
doesn't allow that,
because tuples are immutable.
So why would we
want to use tuples?
Tuples are actually useful in a
couple of different scenarios.
So recall a few years ago,
we looked at this code
where we tried to swap the
values of variables x and y.
And this first code
actually didn't
work, because you're
overwriting the value for x.
So instead, what
we ended up doing
was creating this
temporary variable
where we stored the value of
x, and then we overwrote it,
and then we used the
temporary variable.
Well, turns out this
three liner code right
here can actually be written
in one line using tuples.
So you say x comma y
is equal to y comma x.
And Python goes in and
says, what's the value of y?
And assigns it to x.
And then what's the value of x?
And assigns it to y.
Extending on that,
we can actually
use tuples to return more than
one value from a function.
So functions, you're only
allowed to return one object.
So you're not allowed to
return more than one object.
However, if we use
a tuple object,
and if that's the
thing that we return,
we can actually get
around this sort of rule
by putting in as
many values as we
want inside the tuple object.
And then we can return as
many values as we'd like.
So in this specific
example, I'm trying
to calculate the
quotient and remainder
when we divide x by a y.
So this is a function
definition here.
And down here I'm calling
the function with 4 and 5.
So when I make
the function call,
4 gets assigned to x and
5 gets assigned to y.
So then q is going to be
the integer division when
x is divided by y.
And this double
slash just means--
it's like casting the
result to an integer.
It says divide it, keep
the whole number part,
and just delete everything
else beyond the decimal point.
So when you divide
4 by 5, this q
is actually going to be 0,
because it's 0 point something,
and I don't care about
the point something.
And then the remainder is just
using the percent operator.
So I divide 4 by 5, the
remainder is going to be 4.
And notice that I'm
going to be returning
q and r, which are these
two values that I calculated
inside my function.
And I'm returning them in
the context of this tuple.
So I'm only returning one
object, which is a tuple.
It just so happens that
I'm populating that object
with a few different values.
So when the function
returns here,
this is going to say 0 comma 4.
That's the tuple
it's going to return.
Q is going to be 0 and
r is going to be 4.
So then this line
here-- quot, rem
equals 0, 4-- is
basically this--
it's sort of like
what we did up here.
So it assigns quot to 4-- sorry.
Quot to 0 and rem to 4.
So we can use tuples.
This is very useful.
We can use them to return more
than one value from a function.
So tuples are great.
Might seem a little
bit confusing at first,
but they're actually
pretty useful,
because they hold
collections of data.
So here, I wrote
a function which
I can apply to any set of data.
And I'll explain what
this function does,
and then we can apply
it to some data.
And you can see that you
can extract some very basic
information from whatever
set of data that you
happen to collect.
So here's a function
called get_data,
and it does all of
this stuff in here.
And in the actual code
associated with the lecture,
I actually said what the
condition on a tuple was.
So it has to be a
tuple of a certain--
that looks a certain way.
And this is the
way it has to look.
So it's one tuple.
The outer parentheses out
here represent the fact
that it's a tuple.
And the elements of this tuple
are actually other tuples.
So the first element
is a tuple object,
the second element
and third one is a
tuple object, and so on.
And each one of these
inner tuple objects
are actually going to
contain two elements,
the first being an integer
and the second being a string.
So that's sort of
the precondition
that this function
assumes on a tuple
before it can-- before
it actually can work.
All right.
So given a tuple
that looks like that,
what's the function going to do?
It's first creating
two empty tuple.
One is called nums and
one is called words.
And then there's a for loop.
And notice here the for loop
is going to iterate over
every element inside the tuple.
Remember in strings when we
were able to use for loops that
iterated over the characters
directly as opposed
to over the indices?
Well, we're doing the
same sort of thing here.
Instead of iterating
over the indices,
we're going to iterate over the
tuple object at each position.
So first time through
the loop, t here
is going to be this first tuple.
The second time
through the loop, t
is going to be this tuple.
And the third time, it's going
to be this exact tuple object.
So each time through
the loop, what I'm doing
is I'm going to have
this nums tuple that I'm
going to keep adding to.
And each time I'm going
to create a new object
and reassign it to
this variable nums.
And each time
through the loop, I'm
looking at what the
previous value of nums was.
So what was my previous tuple?
And I'm going to add it
with this singleton tuple.
So it's a tuple of one
character or one element.
This element being
t at position zero.
So you have to sort of
wrap your mind around
how this is working.
So if t is going to be this
tuple element right here,
then t at position zero is
going to be this blue bar here.
So it represents the integer
portion of the tuple.
So as we're going
through the loop,
this nums is going to
get populated with all
of the integers from
every one of my tuple--
inside tuple objects.
So that's basically what
this line here is doing.
At the same time, I'm also
populating this words tuple.
And the words tuple is
a little bit different,
because I'm not adding every
single one of these string
objects.
So t at position one being the
string part of the inner tuple.
I'm actually adding the string
part only if it's not already
in my words list.
So here, I'm
essentially grabbing
all of the unique
strings from my list.
These last sort of three
lines-- three, four lines here
just do a little bit of
arithmetic on it saying,
OK, now I have
all of the numbers
here, what's the minimum
out of all of these,
and then what's the maximum
amount of all these?
And then this unique
words variable
tells me how many unique words
do I have in my original tuple.
So this feels sort of generic,
so let's run it on some data.
So here I have it-- I
tested it on some test data.
And then I got some actual data.
And this actual data
that I wanted to analyze
was Taylor Swift data.
And representing
the integer portion
of the tuple representing a
year and the string portion
of the tuple representing
the person who she
wrote a song about that year.
So some real world data that
we're working with here.
Very important that we
know this information.
OK.
So with this data,
I can run it--
I can plug it into this
function that I wrote up here.
And I'm going to actually
comment this out,
so it doesn't get cluttered.
And if I run it--
this is the part
where I'm calling my function.
I'm calling it with
this data here.
tswift being this
tuple of tuples.
And what I get
back is-- up here,
line 38-- is the return from the
function being a large tuple.
And that large tuple,
I'm then assigning it
to my own tuple in my program.
And then I'm just writing out--
printing out some statement
here.
So I'm getting the minimum
year, the maximum year,
and then the number of people.
So I can show you that
it works if I replace
one of these names
with another one
that I already have in here.
So instead of writing a
song about five people,
she would have wrote a
song about four people.
Yay, it worked.
So that's tuples.
And remeber or recall-- keep
in mind, tuples were immutable.
Now we're going to look at
a very, very similar data
structure to tuples
called lists,
except that instead of
lists being immutable,
lists are going to
be mutable objects.
So much like lists,
they're going
to contain elements of any
type or objects of any type.
You denote them with--
you denote a list
with square brackets
instead of parentheses.
And the difference
being that they're
going to be immutable
objects instead of immutable.
So creating an
empty list, you just
do open close square brackets.
You can have a list of
elements of different types,
even a list of lists.
So one of the
elements being a list.
As usual, you can
apply length on a list,
and that tells you how
many elements are in it.
This is going to tell
you how many elements
are in your list l.
So it's not going to look
any further than that.
So it's going to say, this is
an integer, this is a string,
this is an integer,
this is a list.
It's not going to say how many
elements are in this list.
It's just going to look at the
outer-- the shell of elements.
Indexing and slicing
works the same way.
So l at position 0
gives you the value 2.
You can index into a list,
and then do something
with the value
that you get back.
So l at position 2 says--
that's this value there
and add one to it.
L at position 3, that's
going to be this list here.
Notice it evaluates
to another list.
You're not allowed
to index outside
of the length of the list.
So that's going to give you
an error, because we only
have four elements.
And you can also have
expressions for your index.
So this-- Python just replaces
i with 2 here and says,
what's l at position 1?
And then grabs
that from in there.
OK.
So very, very similar to
the kinds of operations
we've seen on
strings and tuples.
The one difference,
and that's what
we're going to focus on
for the rest of this class,
is that lists are
mutable objects.
So what does that
mean internally?
Internally, that means
let's say we have a list l,
and we assign it-- sorry.
Let's say we have a variable l
that's going to point to a list
with three elements,
2, 1, and 3.
OK.
They're all-- each
element is an integer.
When we were dealing with
tuples or with strings,
if we re-assign-- if we try
to do this line right here,
we've had an error.
But this is actually
allowed with lists.
So when you execute
that line, Python
is going to look at
that middle element,
and it's going to change
its value from a 1 to a 5.
And that's just due to the
mutability nature of the list.
So notice that this list
variable, this variable l,
which originally
pointed to this list,
points to the exact same list.
We haven't created a
new object in memory.
We're just modifying the
same object in memory.
And you're going to see
why this is important
as we look at a few
side effects that
can happen when you have this.
So I've said this a
couple of times before,
but it'll make your
life a lot easier
if you try to think
of-- when you want
to iterate through a list if
you try to think about iterating
through the elements directly.
It's a lot more Pythonic.
I've used that word before.
So this is sort of
a common pattern
that you're going to see where
you're iterating over the list
elements directly.
We've done it over tuples.
We've done it over strings.
So these are identical codes.
They do the exact same
thing, except on the left,
you're going from-- you're going
through 0, 1, 2, 3, and so on.
And then you're indexing into
each one of these numbers
to get the element value.
Whereas on the right,
this loop variable i
is going to have the
element value itself.
So this code on the
right is a lot cleaner.
OK.
So now let's look
at some operations
that we can do on lists.
So there's a lot more
operations that we
can do on lists, because
of their mutability aspect
than we can do on tuples
or strings, for example.
So here's a few of them.
And they're going
to take advantage
of this mutability concept.
So we can add elements
directly to the end
of the list using this funky
looking notation L.append.
And then the element we
want to add to the end.
And this operation
mutates the list.
So if I have L is
equal to 2, 1, 3, and I
append the element
5 to the end, then
L-- the same L is going to
point to the same object,
except it's going to have
an extra number at the end.
5.
But now what's this dot?
We haven't really
seen this before.
And it's going to
become apparent
what it means in a
few lectures from now.
But for the moment,
you can think
of this dot as an operation.
It's like applying a function,
except that the function
that you're applying
can only work
on certain types of objects.
So in this case,
append, for example,
is the function we're
trying to apply.
And we want to
apply it to whatever
is before the dot,
which is the object.
And append has only been defined
to work with a list object,
for example, which is why we're
using the dot in this case.
We wouldn't be able to
use append on an integer,
for example, because
that sort of function
is not defined on the integer.
So for now, you'll sort
of have to remember--
which are functions
that work with a dot
and which are functions
like [? ln, ?] that
aren't with a dot.
But in a couple of lectures, I
promise it'll be a lot clearer.
So for now, just think
of it as whatever
is before the dot is the object
you're applying a function to,
and whatever is after the
dot is the function you're
applying on the object.
So we can add things
to the end of our list.
We can also combine
lists together using
the plus operator.
The plus operator does
not mutate the list.
Instead, it gives
you a new list that's
the sum of those
two lists combined.
So in this case, if L1 is
2,1,3 and L2 is 4, 5, 6,
when we add those
two lists together,
that's going to give us an
entirely new list leaving
L1 and L2 the same.
And that's why we have to assign
the result of the addition
to a new list.
Otherwise, the result is lost.
If you want to mutate a
list directly and make it
longer by the elements
within another list, then
you can use this extend
function or extent method.
And this is going to
mutate L1 directly.
So if L1 was 2,1,3, if you
extend it by the list 0,6,
it's just going to tack
on 0,6 to L1 directly.
So notice L1 has been mutated.
So that's adding
things to lists.
We can also delete
things from lists.
We don't just want to
keep adding to our lists,
because then they
become very, very big.
So let's see how we can delete
some items from our list.
There's a few ways.
First one being can
use this del function.
And this says
delete from the list
L the element at this index.
So you give it
the index 0, 1, 2,
or whatever you want
to-- whatever index
you want to delete
the element at.
If you just want to
delete the element
at the end of the list,
that's the farthest right,
you do L.pop.
If you want to remove a
specific element-- so you know
there's somewhere in your
list there's the number 5,
and you want to delete it
from the list-- then you
say L.remove and you say what
element you want to remove.
And that only removes the
very first occurrence of it.
So if there's two
fives in your list,
then it's only going to
remove the very first one.
So let's take a look at this
sort of sequence of commands.
So we have first L is equl
to this long list here.
And I want to mention that
all of these operations
are going to mutate
our list, which
is why I wrote this comment here
that says assume that you're
doing these in order.
So as you're doing
these in order,
you're going to be
mutating your list.
And if you're
mutating your list,
you have to remember
that you're working
with this new mutated list.
So the first thing
we're doing is
we're removing 2 from our list.
So when you remove
2, this says look
for an element with the value 2
and take it away from the list.
So that's the very
first one here.
So the list we're left with
is just everything after it.
Then I want to remove
3 from the list
and notice there's two of them.
There's this 3 here and
there's this 3 here.
So we're going to remove
only the first one, which
is this one here.
So the list we're left
with is 1,6,3,7,0.
Then we're going to
delete from the list L
the element at position 1.
So starting counting from
0, the element at position 1
is this one here.
So we've removed that, and
we're left with 1, 3, 7, 0.
And then when we
do L.pop, that's
going to delete the element
furthest to the right.
So at the end of the
list, which is that 0.
So then we're left
with only 1, 3, and 7.
And L.pop is often useful,
because it tells you
the return value from L.pop is
going to be the value that it
removed.
So in this case, it's
going to return 0.
I want to mention, though,
that some of the-- so these
functions all mutate the list.
You have to be careful
with return values.
So these are all-- you
can think of all of these
as functions that
operate on the list.
Except that what these functions
do is they take in the list,
and they modify it.
But as functions, they
obviously return something
back to whoever called them.
And oftentimes, they're going
to return the value none.
So for example, if you are
going to do L.remove 2,
and you print that out, that
might print out none for you.
So you can't just assign the
value of this to a variable
and expect it to be
the mutated list.
The list got mutated.
The list that got
mutated is the list
that was passed into to here.
We're going look at one
example in a few slides that's
going to show this.
OK.
Another thing that we can do,
and this is often useful when
you're working with
data, is to convert lists
to strings and then
strings to lists.
Sometimes it might be useful
to work with strings as opposed
to a list and vice versa.
So this first line here,
list s takes in a string
and casts it to a list.
So much like when we cast
a float to an integer,
for example.
You're just casting a
string to a list here.
And when you do
that up this line--
so if this is your s
here-- when you do list s,
this is going to
give you a list--
looks like this-- where
every single character in s
is going to be its own element.
So that means every character
is going to be a string,
and it's going to be
separated by a comma,
so including spaces.
Sometimes you don't want
each character in the list
to be its own element.
Sometimes you want, for example,
if you're given a sentence,
you might want to have
everything in between spaces
being its own element.
So that will give you every word
in the sentence, for example.
In that case, you're
going to use split.
In this case, I've split
over the less than sign.
But again, if you're doing
the sentence example,
you might want to
split on the space.
So this is going to take
everything in between the sign
that you're interested in-- in
this case, the less than sign--
and it's going to set it as a
separate element in the list.
So that's how you
convert strings to lists.
And sometimes
you're given a list,
and you might want to
convert it to a string.
So that's where this join
method or function is useful.
So this is an empty string.
So it's just open
close quote right away.
No space.
So this just joins every one
of the elements in the list
together.
So it'll return the string abc.
And then you can join on any
character that you would want.
So in this case, you can
join on the underscore.
So it'll put whatever characters
in here in between every one
of the elements in your list.
So pretty useful functions.
OK.
Couple other operations
we can do on lists--
and these are also pretty
useful-- is to sort lists
and to reverse lists
and many, many others
in the Python documentation.
So sort and sorted both
sort lists, but one of them
mutates the list and
the other one does not.
And sometimes it's
useful to use one,
and sometimes it's
useful to use the other.
So if I have this list
L is equal to 9,6,0,3,
sorted-- you can think
of it as giving me
the sorted version
of L-- gives you back
the sorted version of L. So
it returns a new list that's
the sorted version of the input
list and does not mutate L.
So it keeps L the
exact same way.
So this will be replaced
by the sorted version
of the list, which you
can assign to a variable,
and then do whatever
you want with it.
Like L2 is equal to
sorted L, for example.
And it keeps L the same.
On the other hand, if you
just want to mutate L,
and you don't care about getting
another copy that's sorted,
you just do L.sort.
And that's going to
automatically sort L for you,
and L now-- L is now the
sorted version of L. Similarly,
reverse is going to take L and
reverse all the character--
all the elements in it.
So the last one is the first
one, the second to last one
is the second one, and so on.
So lists are mutable.
We've said that so many
times this lecture.
But what exactly does that mean?
What implications
does that have?
Once again, this next part
of the lecture, Python tutor.
Just paste all the code
in and go step by step
to see exactly what's happening.
So lists are mutable.
As you have variable
names-- so for example,
L is equal to some
list-- that L is
going to be pointing
to the list in memory.
And since it's a mutable
object, this list,
you can have more
than one variable
that points to the exact
same object in memory.
And if you have more
than one variable that
points to the same
object in memory,
if that object in
memory is changed, then
when you access it through
any one of these variables,
they're all going to give
you the changed object value.
So the key phrase
to keep in mind
when you're dealing
with lists is
what side effects could happen?
If you're mutating a list,
if you're doing operations
on lists, what side effects--
what variables might
be affected by this change?
Let's come back down
to earth for a second.
This will wake a
lot of people up.
So let's do an
analogy with people.
Let's say we have a person.
A person-- this
case, Justin Bieber--
is going to be an object.
I'm an object.
I'm like the number three.
Bieber's an object.
He's like number five.
Different objects.
Were both of type people.
OK.
Let's say a person has
different attributes.
Let's say we can--
let's say he gets
two attributes to begin with.
He's a singer and he's rich.
I can refer to this person
object by many different names.
His full name, his stage
name, all of the fan girls
call him by these
names, people who
dislike him call
him by other names
that they didn't put up here.
But he's known by all
these different names.
They're all aliases or nicknames
that point to this same person
object.
OK.
So originally, let's say
I say Justin Bieber is
a singer and rich.
Those are the two
attributes I've originally
assigned to him.
And then let's say I want to
assign a different attribute
to him and say Justin
Bieber's a singer, rich,
and a troublemaker.
I'm being kind here.
OK.
So if I say Justin Bieber
has these three attributes--
so it's the same person
I'm referring to-- then
all of his nicknames
are going to refer
to this exact same person.
So all of his
nicknames or aliases
will refer to the
same person object
with these changed attributes.
Does that makes sense?
OK.
So that sort of idea
arises in lists.
So a list is like
a person object
whose value-- whose attributes
can change, for example.
And as they change, all
of the different aliases
for this object will point
to this changed object.
So let's see a few examples.
I apologize if this
is a little small,
but this I basically
copied and pasted
from the Python
tutor, which is just
from the code from
today's lecture.
So I have these
lines of code here.
The first couple of
lines really just
show what happens
when you're dealing
with non-mutable objects.
So with non-mutable
objects, you have
two separate objects that
get their own values,
and that's it.
End of story.
With lists, however,
there's something different
that happens.
So I have warm is a variable.
And it's going to be
equal to this list.
So warm is going to
point to this list here.
Red, yellow, orange.
It contains three elements.
Hot is equal to warm.
It means I'm creating
an alias for this list.
And the alias is going to
be with this variable hot.
So notice warm and hot point
to the exact same object.
So on line 8 when I append
this string pink to my object,
since both of
these two variables
point to the exact
same object, if I'm
trying to access this object
through either variable,
they're both going to
print out the same thing.
And that's the side effect.
That's the side effect
of lists mutable.
If you want to create an
entirely new copy of the list,
then you can clone it,
which sounds really cool.
But really, it's just
making a copy of the list.
And you clone it using
this little notation here,
which is open close square
brackets with a colon.
And we've sort of seen
this notation here.
And this tells Python
this is 0-- sorry.
This is 0 and this is length.
Cool.
But it basically says
take every element,
create a new list with
those exact same elements,
and assign it to
the variable chill.
So here, if I
originally have cool
is equal to blue,
green, gray right
here, when I clone it on line
2 with that funky notation,
I'm creating a new copy of it.
And then on the
next line when I'm
appending another
element to the copy,
notice I'm just
altering the copy.
The original stayed the
same, because I've cloned it.
So if you don't want to
have the side effects-- side
effect issue, then
you should clone
your variable-- your list.
So let's see a slightly
more complicated example
where you're going to see
the difference between sort
and sorted in the context
of this mutability and side
effects issue.
OK.
So once again, let's create this
warm is equal to red, yellow,
orange.
So that's what warm is going
to point to, this list.
And then sorted warm
is equal to warm.sort.
So .sort mutates.
So as soon as I do
that, that list warm
is now the sorted version of it.
And notice that I've
assigned the return of this
to sorted warm.
And the return is none,
because L.sort or .sort mutated
the list.
It didn't return a sorted
version of the list.
It mutated the list itself.
OK.
So when I print warm
and I print sorted warm,
I'm printing the mutated
version and then this one here.
Sorted, on the other
hand, returns--
it doesn't-- sorted does not
sort the list that's given
to it.
And instead, it returns a
sorted version of the list.
So in this case, if cool is
equal to these three colors--
gray, green, blue--
if I do sorted cool,
it's going to return the sorted
version of that list, which
is blue, green, gray.
And it's assigned to the
variable sorted cool.
So when I print them,
it's going to show
me the two separate lists.
One being the
original unsorted one,
and one being the
sorted version.
Last ones a little
bit more complicated,
but it shows that even
though you have nested--
even though you can have nested
lists, you still-- you're not--
you don't escape this
idea of side effects.
So first, I'm going to create
warm is equal to these two
colors, yellow, orange.
So warm points to
these two colors.
Hot is equal to this one
list-- a list with one element.
Bright colors is
going to be a list.
And the element inside
the list is a list itself.
So since it's a list--
this is your list,
and the element inside here,
which is a list itself,
is actually just pointing
to whatever warm is.
That object.
Then I do-- then I append
hot to my bright colors.
So the next element
here is going
to be another list, which
means it's just pointing
to this other list here.
It's not creating a copy of it.
So each one of
these elements here
is actually just pointing
to these two lists here.
So if I modified
either one of these,
then bright colors
would also be modified.
So let's say I add pink
here to my hot list.
We have red and pink.
Then notice that bright
colors-- the first element
points to this list,
and the second element
which I've just modified.
Last thing is-- I'll
let you try this
as an exercise in Python Tutor--
but the idea here being you
should be careful as you're
writing a for loop that
iterates over a list that you're
modifying inside the list.
In this case, I'm trying
to go through the list L1.
And if I find an item
that's in L1 and L2,
I want to delete it from L1.
So 1 and 2 are also in L2.
So I want to delete them from
L1 and be left with 3, 4.
However, the code on the
left here doesn't actually
do what I think it's
doing, because here I'm
modifying a list as
I'm iterating over it.
And behind the
scenes, Python keeps
this-- keeps track of the index
and doesn't update the index
as you're changing the list.
So it figures out the
length of the list
to begin with and how
many indices it has.
It doesn't update it as you're
removing items from the list.
So the solution to that is
to make a copy of the list
first, iterate over the copy,
which will remain intact,
and modify the list that you
want to modify inside the loop.
So please run both of
these in the Python Tutor,
and you'll see that what ends
up happening is on the left,
you're going to skip
over one element.
So your code-- so that's
going to be the wrong code.
All right.